>>> MORE NOW ON THE NEW
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY AND THE
PEOPLE TO WATCH MAYBE MORE
CLOSELY THAN OTHERS AS KEVIN
McCARTHY TRIES TO GET HIS
FOOTING AS SPIEAKER.
ONE IS DONALD TRUMP.
HE HELPED SWITCH KEY VOTES IN
THE END AND McCARTHY MADE CLEAR
HE IS GRATEFUL.
ANOTHER IS THE PENNSYLVANIA
CONGRESSMAN SCOTT PERRY.
HE TRIED TO HELP TRUMP STEAL THE
2020 ELECTION, AND HIS ACTIONS
ARE PART OF A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION.
YET PERRY WILL NOT RULE OUT
SERVING ON A NEW HOUSE COMMITTEE
TO INVESTIGATE WHAT REPUBLICANS
CLAIM IS OVERREACH AND ABUSES BY
THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> WHY SHOULD I BE LIMITED, WHY
SHOULD ANYBODY BE LIMITED JUST
BECAUSE SOMEONE HAS MADE AN
ACCUSATION?
EVERYBODY IN AMERICA IS INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN OTHERWISE.
I WOULD SAY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE REALLY, REALLY TIRED OF THE
PERSECUTION AND THE INSTRUMENTS
AND FEDERAL POWER BEING USED
AGAINST THEM.
>> EVERYONE IS INNOCENT UNTIL
FR
PROVEN GUILTY, BUT IS IT NOT A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IF YOUR
NAME IS PART OF AN
INVESTIGATION?
I'M NOT GOING TO USE THE LEGAL
LANGUAGE, BUT THEY WANT TO SEE
TEXT MESSAGES, WE KNOW HE TRIED
TO HELP TRUMP REPLACE THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH SOMEBODY.
HE'S GOING TO BE ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT INVESTIGATES WHAT
THEY BELIEVE TO BE OVERREACHES
BY THE INVESTIGATORS.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T HAVE MUCH MORE TO ADD TO
THAT.
WE KNOW HE'S NOT GOING TO BE THE
CHAIR OF THIS NEW SELECT
SUBCOMMITTEE.
IT'S GOING TO BE JIM JORDAN.
SO HE WON'T LEAD IT.
BUT YEAH, I DON'T KNOW HOW HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO DEAL
WITHDRAWAL IT, ALTHOUGH THEY DO
-- DEAL WITH IT, ALTHOUGH THEY
DO HAVE A DIFFERENT TAKE ON WHAT
IS THE WEAPONIZATION OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
THINGS THEY WILL BE
INVESTIGATING AND JANUARY 6 IS
NOT ONE OF THEM.
>> THEY HAVE A BROAD SCOPE.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THEY
WERE DEBATING WHEN THEY WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
CONCESSIONS.
THEY GOT A HUGE BUDGET.
THEY GOT A REALLY BROAD MANDATE.
SO THEY CAN USE THIS TO GO AFTER
ANY FEDERAL AGENCY AND LOOK INTO
THESE INVESTIGATIONS.
SOME HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR A
SELECT COMMITTEE TO LOOK INTO
JANUARY 6th.
KEVIN McCARTHY SAID NO, HE
DIDN'T WANT TO DO THAT.
I SUSPECT THEY ARE GOING TO TRY
TO USE THIS COMMITTEE TO GO
AFTER SOME OF THESE JANUARY 6
PROBES, AND THIS IS WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE A LOT OF THOSE
HEATED FIGHTS.
>> IT IS A REMARKABLE MOMENT.
ANOTHER THING THAT HAPPENED AT
THE VERY END IS MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, NORMALLY VIEWED AS A
REBEL, BUT SHE'S ON TEAM
McCARTHY BECAUSE HE'S PROMISED
HE'S GOING TO MAKE HER A PLAYER.
HE'S GOING TO GIVE HER COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS.
TO GET THE HANDFU FFUL OF REBEL
VOTE PRESENT, YOU SEE THAT AT
THE TOP, DT, DONALD TRUMP,
TRYING TO HAND IT TO MATT
ROSENDALE, ONE OF THE HOLDOUTS.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE THE CALL
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT THE
PRESSURE FROM DONALD TRUMP.
LISTEN TO MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
WITH HER BIG ROLE.
>> HE YELLED AT ME TELLING ME
DON'T YOU EVER DO THIS.
I WAS SO SURPRISED, I COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND.
I WAS HOLDING OUT MY PHONE
SAYING, IT'S PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE
-- HE WANTS TO SPEAK WITH YOU.
YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP
ENDORSED I THINK ALL 20.
HE HAD TALKED TO THEM MULTIPLE
OF THE 20 -- DURING THE COURSE
OF THE WEEK, URGING THEM TO VOTE
FOR KEVIN McCARTHY FOR SPEAKER
BECAUSE WE HAVE A GREAT AGENDA.
>> IT HAS NOT BEEN A GOOD
STRETCH FOR DONALD TRUMP.
THE 2022 MIDTERMS, REPUBLICANS
DID NOT DO ANYWHERE NEAR AS WELL
AS THEY THOUGHT.
TRUMP SHARES A FAIR AMOUNT OF
THAT BLAME.
THERE YOU HAVE IT AGAIN.
LAST JANUARY, KEVIN McCARTHY
BLAMED TRUMP, SAID TRUMP WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR JANUARY 6th.
THEN HE WENT TO MAR-A-LAGO
QUICKLY SAID, NEVER MIND, I WANT
TO BE SPEAKER, I NEED YOUR
SUPPORT.
TURNS OUT THAT WAS QUOTE/UNQUOTE
CORRECT.
STRATEGICALLY IT HELPED IN THE
END.
BUT HAS YET AGAIN AT A TIME MANY
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO SHOVE
TRUMP A WAY BIG HUG.
>> LIKE THERE'S NO OTHER OPTION
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY OTHER OPTION.
YOU'RE IN NOW.
HE IS TOO IMPORTANT TO CRITICAL
MEMBERS OF YOUR CONFERENCE TO BE
AT ANY OTHER PLACE.
DID I THINK THAT THAT
NECESSITATED KEVIN McCARTHY'S
FIRST WORD AFTER BECOMING
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE BEING TO
THANK AND N GRANDIOSE TERMS
DONALD TRUMP FOR ALL THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENED IN THE WORLD?
PROBABLY NOT.
THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
ALMOST LIKE ONCE YOU'RE IN THIS
DEEPLY YOU HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE.
TO SOME DEGREE, THOUGH, I -- I'M
SKEPTICAL OF THE IDEA THAT THIS
DRAMATICALLY TURNS AROUND HIS
STANDING IN THE SENSE THESE ARE
HIS PEOPLE.
THESE 20, AS MARGELY TAYLOR
GREENE SAID, THEY WERE ENDORSED
BY HIM, WERE ADVOCATES.
STILL TOOK 14 VOTES TO GET
EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND AS
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE SAID HE
WAS STAYING IN TOUCH.
DID HE HELP TURN THEM IN THE
END?
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
IS THAT AS BIG A DEAL AS PEOPLE
ARE FRAMING IT?
I DON'T THINK SO IT IS.
>> IF YOU'RE KEVIN McCARTHY AND
SAYING TRUMP MAY HAVE GOT HIM
OVER THE FINISH LINE, BUT HE
ALLOWED HIM TO BE HUMILIATED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN -- IF HE
REALLY HAD THE POWER TO TURN IT,
WHY DIDN'T YOU TURN IT AFTER THE
SECOND VOTE?
IF I'M KEVIN McCARTHY --
>> UNTIL IT WAS CLEAR THAT HE
WAS ALMOST THERE.
>> RIGHT.
SO LET'S JUST LOOK NOW, AND WE
SHOULD GIVE THESE NEW
REPUBLICANS THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT.
LET'S SEE WHETHER THEY DO
ESSENTIALLY A PERFORMANCE REVIEW
OF THE GOVERNMENT OR AGGRESSIVE
OVERSIGHT THAT GOES TOO FAR.
THE NEW COMMITTEE CHAIR WE KNOW,
JAMES COMER, WILL BE THE
OVERSIGHT, THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE, NOT
REFORM COMMITTEE.
JIM JORDAN IS JUDICIARY, VERY
WELL KNOWN.
MIKE McCALL, FOREIGN AFFAIRS,
MAIN LINE CONSERVATIVE, MIKE
ROGERS, ARMED SERVICES.
MIKE TURNER, THE -- MOST OF
THEM, JORDAN IS A WILD CARD.
MOST FIT THE DEFINITION OF
MAINSTREAM CONSERVATIVE LET'S
SEE.
BUT COMER SAID TODAY WE'RE NOT
JUST INVESTIGATING HUNTER BIDEN,
WE'RE INVESTIGATING JOE BIDEN.
DO THEY HAVE THE DISCIPLINE TO
FOLLOW FACTS AS OPPOSED TO
FOLLOW POLITICS?
>> I WAS JUST CHUCKLING BECAUSE
TWO OF THEIR NAMES ARE MIKE OR
-- THREE ARE MIKE OR MICHAEL,
TWO ARE JAMES OR JIM.
SO THEY ALL HAVE ALMOST THE SAME
NAMES.
BUT THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON THESE REPUBLICAN
CHAIRMEN TO GO WHERE THE BASE
WANTS THEM TO GO.
WHERE THE TRUMP, WHERE THE
MANAGE WING OF THE PARTY WANTS
THEM TO GO.
>> FORGIVE ME FOR INTERRUPTING,
BUT THAT'S DANGEROUS BECAUSE THE
BASE THINKS DONALD TRUMP WON THE
WEST LAST ELECTION, AND HE DID
NOT.
>> RIGHT.
>> THERE'S LEGITIMATE OVERSIGHT
OF HUNTER BIDEN, LEGITIMATE
OVERSIGHT OF THE BORDER,
LEGITIMATE OVERSIGHT OF
GOVERNMENT SPENDING, OF COURSE
THERE IS.
THE QUESTION IS CAN THEY STAY IN
THE LANE OF FACT.
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING IS SOME
REPUBLICANS HAVE SAID THEY DON'T
WANT ANOTHER BENGHAZI-STYLE
COMMITTEE DURING THE LAST TIME
REPUBLICANS WERE IN CONTROL.
OF COURSE THAT HELPED -- HELPED
McCARTHY TO LOSE THE LAST BID
FOR SPEAKERSHIP.
BUT SO HOW'S IT GOING TO BE ANY
DIFFERENT THIS TIME?
THAT'S WHAT I DON'T KNOW.